who what's the one thing that you had to
do that where you're like you know i
have to i'm this is going to take me a
minute to get over
what is the thing that make me get over
i don't know
i'm trying to think that's a really good
question uh put that on the list to get
back to ryan get back because i was
gonna multitask i mean i really
i'll multitask
the thing that really
beyond like some girl that broke up with
me when i was like 22
i mean i've had that i've had i've had
that too sure like i had a show that i
did it lasted two years it was uh decent
ratings uh reviews were pretty good and
then they cancelled it and then just
said this is not what our network is
looking for and i remember going hey
thanks for the work appreciate it and i
didn't think it bothered me i thought i
was good with it
and then all of a sudden i just felt
like
man that was a really good gig i was
really lucky to be a part of that
and it just got kind of got down like
what was it is it me i guess so i'm the
lead
you know you start to doubt yourself and
uh have you done that
yeah i guess i can't think of a specific
project or maybe i'm too guarded about
it maybe you're too great no no no i i
have those moments but like
i don't know the thing that like i
probably hung on to too long i think is
what you're describing
you